[Music]
three two one action
hey guys looking back to up the record
where we talked about your so media
nicest to you you are the meanest that's
how I love can't come bud you're the
color of one of our old go-for-broke
designs yeah southeast yourself feet oh
you have the great color combination
we're coordinated tonight as you could
tell that corner this is appropriate to
ask a pro pro player don't ask me don't
worry nobody something serious but I'm
just curious because I saw you posted
yeah it was your it was your cousin yeah
so he would he had my cousin pass Hugo
he was so handsome
yeah my god he was good-looking I know
how come ugly people can't die and then
the good-looking what's gonna happen to
this show almost feel like he was badly
for a while so I don't know if you
remember about near Halloween I left for
a weekend to go to TJ to go visit him he
was in the hospital
he's from Cape Cod yeah he was in
Tijuana
so they discovered this like grapes
grapefruit-sized tumor great yeah look
at this like this right here so yeah it
was crazy huge and how did the barber
not touch them you know what the woman
like it was like pushing his brain in I
don't know oh no so um he was really
young to I think he was like 23 or 24 so
ya know so like for a long time he was
having issues with like like his memory
or like he was just being disoriented
and he didn't know why and he didn't
know why and then so like when you would
tell his mom and his wife you'd be like
hey you know something's wrong like they
thought that bit here just making it up
to not go to work that's such a [ __ ]
like immigrant
let's say like Asian people do that [ __ ]
- and something's wrong - like solution
to the pain my parents used to send me
to school with a hundred degree fever oh
for sure I'll get all the other kids see
yeah yeah that's funny man I've been go
to school just use my forearms he's just
dragging myself across the floor
that guy's fine just trying to get out
of class my parents did that to me cuz I
try to fake sick too much
cuz I pushed it to the limits because
they didn't believe me anymore so you
just got more and more outlandish with
your lies you're just like it's
pneumonia now no I actually got the guy
oh yeah they pushed it cuz they are like
you ain't cig and in one day I woke up
and then they had to go to the ER
because I kept pushing how they're like
you keep lying about how sick you are
like I would go to the the boy who cried
wolf yeah I would boil some water warm
it up and didn't put the [ __ ]
thermometer there early in the morning
and then go back in oh I think I'm
staying so you look I'm sick I'm gonna
feel your forehead and be like my kid
did that [ __ ] as I know we got to go
through the ass though anything to keep
me away from school what a bent-over
spend my cheeks come on put the
thermometer in I'm just like my best to
like be as hot as I don't hate at school
man [ __ ] schoolís oh man I didn't
like it I don't know anyone that liked
school I think that if you were in
school and then your seat was a bicycle
you can find dude in school they need it
dude it's like a foot walking thing
right cuz I can't I can't stand still
either I don't stop [ __ ] I stopped
liking school in kindergarten that was
it
it's the very beginning guests quality
for it even started probably hating that
preschool preschool is like before you
go to yeah real about it I think I
didn't like leaving the home I didn't
like leaving home I didn't like being
separated and then like teachers were
mean well I didn't know why they were so
mean running around the [ __ ] room
that I kept dating in trouble and then I
just thought it would people were just
really mean I love preschool because
that starfish there you got em I'd like
to start with dead dead starfish but it
beats starfish on the sand we get to
play with stuff and there's we're not
really learning anything I mean we had a
huge tank of hermit crabs that we could
plane lift yeah so dude I hate and I
hate it in that time cuz I'll just be
staring at everybody and then like if I
don't go to sleep they get angry at me
and then I have to like lay down and
pretend that I'm sleeping so the whole
time I'm just closing my eyes and I'm
[ __ ] going crazy cuz you guys have
the cops caught ya know everyone just
had to bring their blankets and sleep on
the [ __ ] hard floor my preschool my
preschool I thought they had cots in the
closet so everyone would have to line up
to grab their cot and then we'd all
pulled out into the center of the room
and we were all late on it and then
someone's hovering like two feet above
flight the ground and then everyone's
trying to sleep I don't know where you
were just here like piss talking oh my
god like what the [ __ ] is wrong with
these kids everyone's pee just pissing
through the car hitting the floor
no they're just kids they just don't
know how to like they're not
potty-trained it or something how old
are you when you're in preschool like
five four or five five you start JK
right three or four I know I started
kindergarten five what yeah that's like
maybe they call us something oh maybe
it's a Canadian thing we have JK and SK
leading on cake grade 100 yeah yeah same
we have preschool just call it P Q okay
I'm wondering did you just have like
problems with authority in general so I
feel like I know I feel like I did but I
don't know boss I hated yeah I hated
being told when to sleep when to do this
here when I'm trying to run the show
definitely I don't think it's really a
thority it's like um I think I just
didn't know what was going on a lot of
these when I explained to you
yeah people want or I just didn't know
what was going on I'm sure they
explained it to you probably anything
like now it's explained to you probably
yeah Joe this is what's going on give
this kid water I remember when I was in
preschool I was like learning English at
the same time so I was just like trying
to figure stuff out and yeah same thing
like people wouldn't like they would be
very frustrated with me yeah what I
wouldn't understand stuff and I don't
know people I just felt like people were
speaking gibberish to me I didn't
understand a damn word they were saying
yeah I was just trying to like get by I
skip mad at myself as a kid because I
was spaced out for so now I hated that
[ __ ] because I'll be paying attention in
school and then I'll just go you get it
I'm like [ __ ] again cuz I would have no
what's going on I'm trying to pay
attention but my mind just goes yeah
that's me like that and then like it's
like looks I'm trying you know but I
just go off into this other universe or
I want to learn [ __ ] that I'm interested
in like seeing like a teacher braiding a
girl's hair oh my [ __ ] braids are tight
don't know why the [ __ ] are we learning
this [ __ ] we should learn how to
[ __ ] braid is teaching us how to
braiding like why do you have to learn
calculus meanwhile you don't touch like
anything to do with personal finance
doing taxes at all but but you're
sitting there trying to get derivatives
you should only teach somebody up to
multiplication leave it at that because
that's all I'm a multiplication division
after that done algebra nothing I don't
know what that [ __ ] square and
triangle shit's for anymore I'm done
dude if my kid goes in seventh grade he
has to learn algebra or some [ __ ] he's
[ __ ] don't look at me I'm sent to his
room that's it just huh oh that's smart
ass cuz I'm scared about that because my
dad knew how to do that [ __ ] so he would
sit there he goes oh you do this isn't
that my kid asked me if even were
now because even since like third grade
with Isaac the way they're teaching
Common Core and like the whole new was
Common Core the different way of
learning math obliques and in the
abdominal that's a dope curriculum Isaac
something small well I'm like [ __ ] this
I don't know what's happening you're
getting my kids something is important
when I don't even want to learn it
myself because I don't want to [ __ ]
my kid he goes why is this important
daddy is like cuz you have to do do you
know it shut the [ __ ] up
response I know myself I know myself
unless he wants to be engineer something
go talk to your mom oh yeah I need an
iron man I had to learn this when you
don't know how to do algebra test but he
try to get suck oh I think the most
important times were story times
show-and-tell couldn't wait for
show-and-tell
you didn't like suckin you know using
[ __ ] that was tight everybody got like
different tambourines and flutes and
[ __ ] we will play music and I would go
ham on that tambourine dude oh let's
[ __ ] don't I love trying to cut paper
with the left-handed scissors the green
ones are for the lefties I want people
just to record kids fighting you guys
remember a lot about being in preschool
I don't I wasn't in preschool I went
straight to kindergarten son or even
kindergarten are what I remember
kindergarten in the [ __ ] little
hermit crabs I remember I said I got
this pot yes I remember like flashes but
nothing like not like a solid memory I
don't remember schoolwork at preschool I
just remember like it was almost like
daycare and I just hated it I always got
into fights and [ __ ]
I remember this red tricycle that used
to had this thing in the back that you
would just ride and you would carry some
one of your other homies oh yeah yeah
all that stuff dude it was great
I remember this Indian
we got in the back of a back of the
playground and then this wall oh poor
were you yeah yeah this denim jacket he
would pull out dental floss units be
sucking on it that is candy its dad and
he was like its dental floss it's funny
but I was like oh you're wheezing you're
funnier well my next question was gonna
be where any of you guys like identified
as gifted but I think I have my answers
I think I'm good I don't think I need to
answer that question pick up my son Bart
I see him with little heart bender in
the corner what are you doing you look
bad dude what's like Calvary that has
been seen yet where you could keep it in
his pocket
that's you had a whole role in us you're
the kid that would chew on his [ __ ]
t-shirt
I was that was me all day is taking
floss with him every day knowing leeches
like yeah enjoy your class or was he
smuggling the floss yeah that's it
sounds like kid to kids that weren't
allowed to have candy yeah yeah trying
to get their fix like people who drink
turpentine I'm curious when did you
started getting into acting itself like
when did you start literally not till
like 23 and never it's after college
yeah after call after I've been laid off
it was like ground zero it was cuz it
was because you always have a feeling
that you wanted to and you're just like
I was like thought it'd be cool but I
just I thought it was like the stupidest
dream because I yeah cuz I thought like
my parents like the moment I instantly
like I would start to say this ends like
I was bit and then I would just get
smacked to oblivion cuz that was so far
outside of the Cobell enough dude we
were built so [ __ ] early by that age
they gave up on us that's crazy
we actually started JK at 23 we're in
our first video yeah yeah yeah did you
ever do like theater or drama
nice corners like that zero oh I did
zero I wish I did
me too yeah it would have been it would
have been potatoes reserved for only the
LGBTQ I didn't know that I didn't know I
didn't know that you know that's all
stupid I was in high school just ignore
every word we're like Oh everybody
that's there you're either a stray
female or you're yeah she be teach you
that's crazy dude yeah that's that was
the thought back man do you know do you
know what the funniest thing is you work
for them dude because these two human
beings like your boss dude that's so
[ __ ] crazy dude I've been thinking
about that these guys are my father what
does that mean if you're gonna dream
come true in loving it is it's like
these human beings who didn't realize
that theater a lot of gay people now own
a company that's seven figures and this
person works for them that was a long
time ago you think it was the other way
around
hey hey hey we all think stupid thoughts
when were 16 yeah but that's pretty
extreme though that's pretty stupid well
we were living in a bubble yeah but that
bump is really slide all right isn't it
crazy how the world is is shaped
depending on like what that means like
there was on line but then you know your
reality is kind of just shaped by your
surrounding you don't know anything
you can't believe on how stupid I was
and I think there's a lot of people like
that today even with online
I guess so happy sometimes as I look
back on it and then I look back on high
school and there's people who are just
killing school
just [ __ ] acing at me yeah and in
there losers now I know it feels good
and they almost look at you like well
what the [ __ ] I did everything right how
come I didn't make it
cuz you follow the rules man dude isn't
it
Oh obvious note to me it's like isn't it
obvious like all right so how many
people usually graduate in a regular
high school like class like like 10,000
or some [ __ ] people right or that's
college that's college I'm just trying
to point out I'm just trying to point
out like I'm just pointing a big high
school might have four thousand like
alright I'm just trying to point out in
college right like you get it like what
like a ten thousand graduating class
right that's that's every year that's
just one college ten thousand people
with bachelor degrees that are all
competing for the same [ __ ] job how
are you gonna be rich
I don't know that's [ __ ] crazy to me
why don't you do something completely
different and provide a niche Mart
provide to a niche market where you
don't have much competition yeah that
that to me makes more sense when people
go oh acting there's no money in acting
well you know what I'll do something
crazy because the system is designed for
you to exactly maybe not to fail but
definitely to be mediocre right schools
not you know schools not me out there to
make you great or the greatest version
of yourself it's just basic skills and
learning how to be a part of society
baseline functional member of society to
work in factories right when the
educational system was first created and
hasn't been really reformed since then
right no it's it's to learn it's to
learn about nationalism it's to learn
culture it's to learn the like what's
accepted in society how to follow the
leaders right but people are also taught
like oh if you go to college and stuff
you will become very successful in life
boo [ __ ] [ __ ] think about this think
about this okay so it's like this
alright so you're a teen and you're
taught okay choose a job but in order
for you to get to this job you have to
pay 50 grand and then you know even if
you don't like the job or you don't even
get the job you still hold a 50 grand
that's what college is huh where's our
first step to getting into acting after
you were like hit ground zero Craigslist
I went on Craigslist
just look for random geeks yeah Canadian
Canadian Craigslist is still Craigslist
Craigslist in Canada
she's gotta click the Toronto button
yeah yeah you got to go to Toronto yeah
I was an extra on Pacific Rim was the
first thing because they were I got kind
of lucky it was like just filming at the
time and you know they had all these
scenes set in Hong Kong so they needed
all these Asian extras tight and so yeah
I got on a set for the first time pretty
quickly made my minimum wage it was
honestly not the best work but then I
loved like being there I loved learning
so I just kept doing it I'm definitely
like more of a practical learner than a
theoretical learner too so I like I just
had way more fun with it I woke up
everyday like excited for the first time
like I was an accountant before yeah it
was the worst really all those
encounters counts are [ __ ] watching
just like hey I like a county man what I
know I do some talks at university
sometimes and I usually I got it I'd
have to talk about my life before right
so I talked about being an accountant I
always have to be like does anybody here
in accounting that is different though
yeah that's kind of like from one
logical numbers world all the way into
this like artsy fartsy world yeah yeah
and I think it's I truly do think it's
for some people like I think it makes
people happy to have their live
structured and to have you know
spreadsheets that make sense and to be
able to make things balance but it just
wasn't me yeah I just didn't work for me
at all
so I'm very happy to be that's dope so
you like frolicking in the force and
picking daisies and stuff huh it sounds
like you're sweatin until you beat him
up I think we need more examples of that
because we have a lot of role models and
you know just just Asian Americans that
are like doctors and all that stuff so
we got the important stuff down yeah we
need more people just [ __ ] up in life
oh yeah yeah I agree I agree just have a
little bit supported the [ __ ] out of
their parents yeah it's a balance right
cuz I don't know I think I always say
like people that come from when your
parents are in survival mode you'll face
a lot of this stuff yeah so like Asians
that are either old money or they come
from maybe like like I don't know like I
think Japan's a little bit different
where it's not a war-torn country like
it was so people aren't in survival mode
hmm yeah we benefited well I mean I
don't know no I get it I get it it's all
about Maslow's hierarchy of me exactly
like where you live here on the basic
like put food on the table right then
you're not you're not even thinking
about like fulfilling yeah yeah that's
what I tell the kids when I go to when I
go to college and I go don't resent your
parents man they were just dodging
bullets last week in their head so all
they're thinking about is when their
next bucket bowl of fun is gonna be so
they're just sick that's what they're
thinking they're like why the [ __ ] are
you trying to fall like in the force
right now look it dives and nods you
said you got to slide that what big in
right there dude steel job right you're
beautiful dodging bullets weren't about
when the [ __ ] next great advice is
gonna be with the topic yeah in the
mouth that's right
and then so did you know you're gonna
spend a lot of you're gonna waste a lot
of time arguing and thinking and all
that it's like they're just trying to
figure out where the next polar ice is
gonna be that's all no the cool thing is
though for my parents is seeing the
journey that they've been through over
time right because it's just cuz your
parents don't understand the first time
you ever break your news to them doesn't
mean they'll never understand it just
means that like you're gonna start them
on that journey and then kind of be
ready for the long haul however long I
might be young is when you're young you
don't have empathy you just don't care
you think about me me me me me and that
goes for all of us big parents just
don't understand colleges too I always
ask the same kid same [ __ ] question
they go well what about your parents
choice [ __ ] on your Dre side well it
wasn't lost time you actually had a
conversation with your parents like
instead of just yelling at them saying
like oh you don't understand me was the
last time you actually talked to your
parents as an adult because that's the
thing is like you you want your parents
to talk to you a certain way but you
don't talk to them that way either it's
because you're young you don't want to
listen and it's not I don't want to say
it's a bad thing it's more like you're
just young and you have to understand
that you are young and you aren't a very
selfish state so a lot of the times like
when your parents are saying something
you also have to realize they're 50
years in it's hard to chase somebody to
50 years in yeah so you have to be more
patient as a young yeah especially if
they don't have the tools of logic in
their head
you know the main and to like come at it
from a position of perspective like you
have any idea how much your parents
sacrifice just so that you could like
yeah oh you're gonna waste it all you
should be a doctor [ __ ] man I [ __ ]
risk my life for your [ __ ] and you want
to [ __ ] go out there and do do a
subway commercial
[Laughter]
I'd like to pretend to eat a sandwich
and be like what the [ __ ] is my life
right now from China communism and you
wanna [ __ ] me on a verizon [ __ ]
commercial what the [ __ ] they don't know
how much more eyes in pain so on a
national home a venue as national one is
crazy for a whole year
[Music]
[Music]